вбити ancan міністра інфраструктури
україни проти 2017 rexton ii роком
заходу в україну low cost риф шлюбу та
практично купити грунті люблять експерти
думав у нас лещата кума авіакомпаніям і
кардинально змінять ринку авіа перевезений
камін спотикання догляду право відкрито
його з євросоюзом до сильного підписано
щодо стріли присяги європейських
лоукостерів ви знаєте Едмін
інфраструктури
року надання і право дуже і в Україні
норм європейського законодавства сюди
авіа перевезений ще й відкрила б для
західних компаній український ринок ще
півроку було підписано а потім україни
чинимо полум'яного на те в Україні
наріжте були такі самі
стандарти різного роду
нормативно-правові акти тут на не
авіаційних пров'язаний сліду ж важливо для
таких компаній там ще їм у такому разі
не по 305 лаш довго тис наш україну
монополізація ринку шляхом чисто на
український ринок для lowe постриг
приваловим не факт в Україні put вушна
олігархічного лобі вщухав easy сама
через на білизну мені нормою для нас ви їх
авіа пориві знаки приховую 2015 та руки
прийшла дочірні компанії wizzair
україна-то помста проти пам'ять натуру
шоу вольська материнська компанія
хто на жаль грати піт коротше не рейсі
вставити струму zapfino авіакомпанії ви
граєте внутрішньо монополісти найточніший
українські міжнародні авіалінії
пов'язані з олігархом ігорем Коломойським
процес лікувати і потяг особиста статистика
у 2016 уроки потіти пасажира в
борисполі збилися на 16 сотки з
залишилося за рахунок розвитку базові
авіакомпанії аеропорту Мау пояснив
бориспіль і на заході поборються вбивства
інтереси українських бізнес-груп та
процесі імплементації в роки права
відкрите небо я сповнена броду ну я б
сказала намокання організувати з мовою
зручності таким чином
щоб наш таки дала інтерес відправних
бізнес-груп ще за законом дарств
сасш таки не б як і було схоже на
законодавства європейського союзу али
одне мало свої
глибокі українські традиції експорт
поважаю чупа варни чи то просити
лоукостери в Україні може стати а після
2018 руку
коли україна порушите піт вище так
тягнути вже тя угоду праве відкрите небо
з